[Music]
okay
i'm going to start this video by saying
i fall into the age group defined as
millennial
i was born in 1993 the year jurassic
park graced theater screens for the
first time
snoop dogg's debut album sold 800 000
copies its first week
and women were first allowed to wear
pants on the senate floor what a year
in this video i'm going to say some
things about millennials that some
people may disagree with but i'm also
going to give previous generations the
same treatment
but most of all i'm going to talk about
why generational labels are pointless in
the first place
let's start by defining what people mean
when they say generation
a generation in this context is a group
of people born within a fairly arbitrary
range of dates
for example you're a baby boomer if you
were born between 1946 and 1964.
you're part of generation x if you were
born between 65 and 1980 or
61 and 81 depending on who you ask
you're a millennial between 81 and 96
and kids born in or after 1997 are
called post-millennials
yep millennials are so bad that the
entire next generation is defined by the
fact that they're not millennials
let's play a game i'm going to list some
stereotypes and you try to guess which
generation i'm talking about lazy
entitled disrespectful
self-centered impatient if you guessed
any generation at all you're right
george orwell once said every generation
imagines itself to be more intelligent
than the one that went before it
and wiser than the one that comes after
it and he was absolutely right
here's a quote for you try to guess what
decade it comes from
i see no hope for the future of our
people if they are dependent on the
frivolous youth of today
when i was young we were taught to be
discreet and respectful of elders
but the present youth are exceedingly
disrespectful and impatient
so what do you think which decade do you
think that came from
trick question we can't say for certain
it's from somewhere around the 8th
century
people have been lumping their children
and their elders into groups for the
purpose of complaining about them since
basically the dawn of time
does that mean complaints about any
given generation are invalid
no of course not there are very specific
and valid concerns about every group
let's look at millennials for example
we're addicted to our phones and social
media
we're more depressed than any previous
generation we have very little respect
for what used to be seen as a stable
career
and we're incredibly entitled a lot of
you watching this probably agreed with
all those
and i'm sure that at least as many of
you disagreed let's break this down
there are two big problems with these
stereotypes one
they're stereotypes they are by default
highly generalized assertions about a
very very large group of people spanning
a hugely diverse background
in fact millennials are the most diverse
generation in history
now all stereotypes are based on some
grain of truth however small it may be
yes most of us are addicted to our
phones but i'm sure we all know at least
one person who actively tries to
distance themselves from smartphones and
social media
yes we have higher rates of depression
than any previous generation but that's
partly due to the social media
and here we reach the second problem
with these stereotypes not a single one
of them is caused by some unique quality
of people born between 1981 and 1996.
they're caused by a number of factors
but mainly by the people who raised them
yes millennials have been spoiled by
participation trophies but whose idea
was that
thanks dad just kidding my parents are
lovely but seriously the participation
trophy thing is a problem
when every child is given an award for
being absolutely unremarkable
you end up with a generation of young
adults who expect to be rewarded just
for showing up
yeah that's a bad thing to expect but
the millennials who exhibit that
tendency had no choice in the matter
they were raised in an environment of
constant praise and assertions that they
can do anything they put their minds to
we're addicted to our smartphones why
because smartphones weren't a thing when
our parents were growing up
millennials got to be the guinea pigs
for a culture-wide experiment that ended
up shattering our perception of reality
and leading to drastically increased
rates of depression and suicide
it sounds dramatic but think about how
social media works
we post a status somebody likes it we
get an instant hit of dopamine
the same sneaky chemical that activates
the reward centers of our brains when we
drink or smoke or gamble
dopamine is incredibly addicting and
social media is the ultimate delivery
tool
it's easy we always have our phones on
us and it doesn't seem as dangerous as
alcohol or nicotine
as far as career aspirations go when
millennials are overwhelmingly
hamstringed by crippling student loans
and if we're lucky maybe landed an
unpaid internship during school
and when we get out our job prospects
are still no better than our high school
educated peers
the eagerness fades a little top that
off with the fact that most entry-level
positions pay worse adjusted for
inflation than the jobs our parents
landed
and require 5 years of experience the
options seem both limited and depressing
so yes many millennials have a bad
attitude but the reasons are more valid
than a lot of people assume
this isn't just a defensive millennials
each generation has to take
responsibility for the environment they
provide for their children
the baby boomers who largely held the
opinion that loyalty to a company and
putting in long hours was the surest way
to move up in the world
struggled to understand why their gen x
children were apathetic about careers
and angry at society
sure the boomers were well off but many
of them didn't make time for their
families which led their children to
strive for more independence from
corporations and a better work-life
balance
of course as with anything related to
generations this is all very general
there were baby boomers with a great
work-life balance there were gen
xers who didn't drive iroc camaros while
wearing flannel shirts torn jeans and
listening to duranduran
just like there are millennials who just
want to find a decent 9-5 job and
support their family
unfortunately this whole cultural norm
of lumping huge numbers of people into
generations has the negative effect of
creating an us vs them mentality
if i hear one more person blame
millennials for killing retail chains or
golf or home ownership i'm going to slap
them with my avocado toast
this happens with every generation
society changes
the way we do business changes cultural
norms media
job markets political landscapes
everything changes
and change is scary for the people who
are too tired to keep up
yes technology moves quickly but that's
no excuse to blame smartphones for the
downfall of western civilization
plenty of people are adapting to and
taking advantage of every new
opportunity or breakthrough that comes
their way
the bottom line is this generational
stereotyping is simply based on bad
assumptions
it assumes that entire populations of
people share the same values the same
upbringing the same likes or dislikes
the same psychological tendencies
donald trump is a baby boomer so is bill
gates
they're on opposite sides of every
possible spectrum
both very wealthy one gives 95 of his
income to charity
the other was busted for running a
fraudulent charity jeff bezos is a gen
xer so was kurt cobain they probably
wouldn't have gotten along
then take millennials lebron james is a
millennial
and so is kim jong-un besides the fact
that they both like basketball
not very much in common additionally the
idea that generations exhibit totally
different values is also wrong and
counterproductive
if a baby boomer and a millennial would
just take the time to listen to each
other rather than assuming things based
upon generational stereotypes
they could very well find that they
share some similar values
these values could be anything from
political views to adopting shelter
animals to just wanting to have the time
to relax with friends and family so
to recap in this video we have
complained about millennials
complained about people complaining
about millennials probably triggered
both groups of people
asserted that generational labels are
stupid and use generational labels to
explain things
if that sounds ridiculous it should this
counterproductive arguing about why
young people are lazy or why old people
are out of touch
or any of the pointless fighting over
inevitable social changes has been going
on for as long as we've had recorded
history
and probably much longer than that maybe
these so-called
post-millennials can break the vicious
cycle but i don't know
they seem pretty lazy if you enjoyed
this episode consider subscribing to
support the channel
if you think i'm stupid leave a thumbs
down and tell me why in the comments
below
check out these playlists to watch my
other content and as always
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next week